kommen wir nun aber zur Königsdisziplin
der deutschen Politik Probleme so lange
ignorieren bis sie einem in den Arsch
beißen ja Stichwort Beamtenversorgung in
den nächsten Jahren hier sitzen einige
in den nächsten Jahren gehen in
Deutschland ohne Ende Beamte in Pension
und das wird mehrere Bundesländer
finanziell überfordern das wissen alle
Beteiligten schon seit Jahren gemacht
hat keiner was tja müssen sich die
Jüngeren eben mal was einfallen lassen
wie sie das später finanzieren wollen ja
natürlich weil die
die wollten doch unbedingt die vielen
Beamten einstellen damals in den 70ern
und 80ern ach das war die gar nicht guck
an ja allein in den letzten zehn Jahren
sind die Versorgungsausgaben für Beamte
von Bund Ländern und Kommunen um
unglaubliche 50% gestiegen und liegen
jetzt schon bei 60 Milliarden pro Jahr
blöd
finden Sie erst gerecht das Beamte und
Beamtinnen nicht in die Rentenkasse
einzahlen tja da können wir den König
von Preußen noch mal fragen also seitdem
ist das so ungefähr ja
gut dann fragen wir nächste Mal den
König von Preußen
vielleicht kann der sich ja noch an
seine Gespräche mit der warburgbank
erinnern
und ich weiß was jetzt denken keine
Angst wir führen jetzt hier nicht die
übliche night Debatte natürlich haben
Beamte Pensionsansprüche die man nicht
in Frage stellen darf logisch so leider
wird in Deutschland seit 2015 aber schon
wieder mehr verbeamtet das heißt da
tickt wirklich eine Zeitbombe vor allem
in den länderhaushalten man könnte auch
sagen eine boomerbombe und wenn mir das
weiter aussitzen sind wir auch nicht
besser als die Typen bei Peter zwega die
ihre Post nicht mehr aufmachen ja dann
sind wir kein bisschen besser meine
Damen und Herren
in Nordrhein-Westfalen Nummer als
Beispiel hier in NRW machen die
Beamtenpensionen schon 35 Prozent der
gesamten Personalkosten des Landes aus
gleichzeitig stellt man fest Träumen
immer mehr coole junge Leute plötzlich
vom uncoolen öffentlichen Dienst einige
Stellen sich das Ganze möglicherweise
etwas zu relaxt vor ich könnte mir
vorstellen vielleicht am Anfang
irgendwas mit Kanzlei wo man viel Geld
verdienen zu machen und dann kurz bevor
man noch ins Baden Verhältnis eintreten
kann dann vielleicht als Richter so
entspannt die Termine immer
nachmittags zu verlegen und so das
könnte ich mir schon vorstellen jawollo
ja das könnte sich vorstellen nice
ausschlafen und nachmittags auf Lock ein
Weg Richtung
geiler Plan Digger so aktive Beamte sind
für den Staat preiswerter als
Angestellte weil man die Sozialabgaben
spart logisch das heißt aber man
verschiebt quasi die Versorgung seiner
Beamten in die Zukunft auf Kosten der
jüngeren Generation ja das ist so der
jüngeren Generation die dann weniger
Spielräume hat für Bildung Klima oder
Infrastruktur soweit gehört allerdings
auch Beamte müssen dem Staat rund um die
Uhr zur Verfügung stehen okay die
Öffnungszeiten der meisten Bezirksämter
sagen was anderes aber egal ne plus
natürlich sie müssen stets gute Manieren
zeigen das heißt als Beamter auch
außerhalb der Arbeitszeit daran denkt
dass er den Staat repräsentiert also
immer eine gewisse Würde
einen gewissen Anstand waren muss und
sich nicht so gehen lassen kann wie der
normale Bürger
ja ja das kann sich der normale
Angestellten Pöbel hier im Studio gar
nicht vorstellen ja ist doch so ihr
könnt ungewaschen jeden Tag mit offener
Hose zur Arbeit gehen ne
mach da ja auch aber vielleicht mal quer
gedacht vielleicht kriegen die Beamten
in Deutschland auch gar nicht zu viel
sondern alle anderen zu wenig deshalb
unser Vorschlag wir verbeamten einfach
alle Bewohner von Deutschland Babys
werden noch im Kreißsaal verbeamtet
ebenso Influenza ampeljongleure
Yogalehrer Hunde und natürlich Kiwi und
das komplette Fernsehgarten Publikum sie
alle kriegen das Recht auf Teilzeit plus
eine fette Pension und der Klo die
Rechnung zahlen irgendwann später diese
ständig genervten jungen Leute die wie
mochten die heute schon fordert
bedingungslose grundverbeamtung jetzt
alle Beamten ja fordern wir heute so und
weil ihr alle zu gut gelaunt seid nur
mal am Rande erwähnt in Österreich hat
man vor 20 Jahren angefangen die
Versorgung von Beamten und Angestellten
schrittweise zusammenzuführen bis dann
irgendwann in paar Jahren alle in die
Rentenkasse einzahlen unsere Nachbarn
wir denken eben immer nur von einer Wahl
zur nächsten mediziner sprechen von
Walsheimer
gerade für Haushaltspolitiker bleibt es
verlockend Rechnungen in ferne Zukunft
zu verschieben und für bestimmte Berufe
ja für bestimmte Berufe macht das nach
wie vor Sinn für Polizei zum Beispiel
aber was für ein Wahnsinn Freunde das
inzwischen wieder sämtliche Bundesländer
neue Lehrer verbeamten weil man sich die
gegenseitig abjagen will ja so bleibt es
also bei der schlimmen zwei
Klassengesellschaft in unseren Schulen
sie wissen ja das sitzt der Angestellte
Pädagoge im Lehrerzimmer und mümmelt
seine Käseschnitte dann kommt der braun
gebrannte bar ten Kollege rein der
gerade sechs Monate bei vollen Bezügen
in der Burnout Dreher war was der
Angestellte sich gar nicht leisten
könnte weil er ja nach sechs Wochen nur
noch Krankengeld kriegt ja der Beamter
hat gut ne also während der Beamte
privatversichert ist mehr Netto vom
Brutto kriegt und kündbar ist und zwar
egal was er macht
außerdem haben Beamte im Schnitt eine
vier Jahre höhere Lebenserwartung als
der Rest von uns ich sage ihnen gerecht
gerecht ist das alles nicht
ja meine man könnte ja neue Lehrer auch
mal mit besseren Arbeitsbedingungen
anlocken aber jetzt fange ich wirklich
an zu spinnen
keine Frage ganz wichtig Neid macht
hässlich aber krasse Ungleichbehandlung
wird auf Dauer auch zum Problem die
Boomer Bombe Beamtenversorgung höchste
Zeit damals einen echten Boomer zu Wort
kommen zu lassen dietmarschmeyer
Terra nix Deutschlands letzte Paradise
mit Dietmar Wischmeyer
mitten unter uns lebt die letzte fast
sorgenfreie unter Spezies des Homo
sapiens Beamte des öffentlichen Dienstes
unbeeindruckt von maroden Staatsfinanzen
hocken sie ihren komfortnestern und
brüten immer neue Beamtenanwärter aus
wenn er eins der letzte das Licht
ausmacht in Deutschland dann ist es
garantiert der dafür zuständige Beamte
sie sind überall Lehrer Finanzen
bauantragsverhinderer manche sind auch
einfach nur da und haben sie sich erst
einer Sache angenommen kommt das Leben
zum Stillstand jeder Politiker kämpft
vergebens gegen den gemästeten
Berufsstand an meist aber auch nicht
weil er selber ein Beamter ist
für junge Menschen die vom Leben nichts
erwarten außer es unfallfrei hinter sich
zu bringen mit der staatsaffi zu
einzigen alternative wozu sich auf der
Straße festkleben wenn es auch auf einem
Sessel im mittleren gehobenen Dienst
geht der zwischenzeitical und
Vorruhestand ordentlich ranklotzt und
den ein oder anderen Brückentag
ausnahmsweise durch malocht hat mit Ende
30 seine 40 Dienstjahre voll und das
beste kommt zum Schluss kann sich auf
die Pension freuen zwischendurch eine
Weiterbildung in Zumba Tanz oder nackt
Bogenschießen und der brutale Büroalltag
verliert sein Schrecken wenn er denn
überhaupt noch im Büro stattfindet das
Homeoffice lässt sich überall
aufschlagen denn ein Beamter ist immer
im Dienst
selbst wenn der herr Ober Regierungsrat
auf den Bock ansitzt ist er im Geister
bei seiner Behörde anders als der
wildlebende Homo sapiens kennt er keine
Existenzängste blöderweise geraten Bund
und Länder als Hotel Mama für
Staatsdiener dabei selbst in Existenz
Nöte hinzu kommt und das wissen wir aus
Studien dass eben auch gerade die
beihilfekosten also die
Gesundheitsversorgung der Pensionäre
exorbitant hoch ist und auch weiterhin
steigen wird das liegt vor allem daran
dass Beamte schon jetzt im Schnitt älter
werden als der Durchschnitt der
Bevölkerung der medizinische Fortschritt
wird die Kosten zusätzlich in die Höhe
treiben das ist die Kehrseite des
medizinischen Fortschritts hier sollte
man allmählich gegensteuern es geben so
einige Möglichkeiten wie wäre es mit
dieser hier der Staat schenkt jedem
Beamten zur Pensionierung ein nagelneues
pedeleck sie werden von der nervigen
Helmpflicht befreit und man verschweigt
ihn dass ihr neues Pedelec sagen wir mal
frisiert wurde
Abflug ins ewige Sabbatical doch niemals
geht man so ganz es bleibt dir noch die
beamtenwitwe in der Blüte ihrer Jahre
hatte sich an einen kränklichen
Staatsdiener angewandt und kriegt jetzt
im Schnitt 1.830 Euro jeden Monat 300
mehr als ein Rentner der 45 Jahre lang
ins kaputte System eingezahlt hat auch
in Sachen schwarze Witwe müsste man
eventuell mal out of the box denken zum
Beispiel an die altindische witwenlösung
aber es wird nicht nur so als erste Idee
guten Abend
so und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take
aus heute